Wow!
Hello everybody!
Wait, let me put up my lo-fi.
I have like 20 tabs up right now.
Give me a sec.
Alright, here we go.
Lo-fi!
Yay!
Now we're actually comfy!
Let's go!
Oh, today was a very long day today.
We're so close to 700k!
I don't think we're getting it at the end of the stream, but I just thought...
It'd be nice to have it there.
It'd just be nice to...
To have the counter there.
Nice, yeah.
But what a long, exhausting day we had today.
Yeah, we sort of...
We sort of low-key overdid it today in terms of streaming.
I don't know what it is about Overwatch.
Something about Overwatch just makes me go like crazy.
Oh yeah!
I didn't realize!
You guys know like the alpha test for Marvel Rivals?
For Marvel Rivals is actually like...
It's coming out next week?
I think?
I think it's next week, right?
Yeah, it's coming out on Friday.
The alpha test.
I actually didn't realize that.
That's crazy.
I noticed... I just saw... I saw like...
Because I was like... I made the joke about like...
Oh, this is going to be like Marvel Rivals waiting room.
By the way...
Fucking shitty name.
It's a really bad name.
I'll admit.
Marvel Rivals.
It just doesn't...
I think it's because like...
It just doesn't roll off the tongue very well.
Marvel Rivals...
It feels like a tongue twister.
You know?
Marvel Rivals, Marvel Rivals...
It just feels like...
Feels like a fucking tongue twister.
Not like...
It's like, you know, Apex Legends.
Overwatch.
Fortnite.
Like, these are things that roll off your tongue.
Very easily.
But Marvel Rivals is such a terrible name.
For...
It's such a terrible name.
For a game title.
Um...
It just sounds really mad.
I wish it was a different name.
Uh...
But I signed up...
I signed up for like the alpha test.
But it says like they're...
I was reading it up.
And it said that they're planning on taking in 30,000 people.
Uh...
30,000 people.
For the alpha test.
So like, if any...
You know, if anybody has any connections to...
Um...
All I'm saying is that if anybody has any connections to NetEase or like the developers of Marvel Rivals and you know, you guys could like sneak me in.
So like I can...
You know, I can do like a play through test.
You know?
I can...
I can give you guys content.
Publicity.
I could give you publicity.
Chat.
Like...
Guys.
Any...
Any Marvel Rivals devs in chat?
I can...
Come on.
My...
I signed up.
Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There was no toxicity in Overwatch.
Just like there's no war in Ba Sing Se.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Oh my god.
Um...
I had a game.
It was actually fucking crazy.
It was...
It was so...
I had a game.
Holy shit!
I had it!
I had a game where there was a Reaper one trick on the enemy team and he was really fucking bad.
So then like, I think like one of our teammates called him out and was like...
Cause like the Mercy player on the enemy team was like...
This was off stream.
The Mercy player on the enemy team was like, report our Reaper.
He's trolling.
And then the Reaper was like, no report our Mercy.
She's like pistolling from spawn.
And one of the teammates on my team was like...
Bro, not gonna lie.
You're pretty... You're not gonna lie.
You're a pretty bad player.
Like, that's the Reaper one trick.
And he was like...
The person on my team was like, you know, we should all report the...
He was like in the all chat, you know, we should report you for being a terrorist.
You're a terrible player.
And then...
And then, okay, and then it escalated because the teammate...
My teammate was like, you should kill him.
I was like...
I was like, weekly!
And then the enemy Reaper straight up dropped a gamer word.
Holy shit!
And then...
And then the enemy, the Reaper one trick straight up was like, gamer word.
Everyone
in all chat was straight up was like, whoa!
Like, both were bad.
But one was worse than the other because I can't say the gamer word.
So obviously I reported the gamer word Reaper one trick.
And I got...
I got the report be like, thank you for reporting on this person.
We have banned them.
And you know, you know, they're so used to...
They're so used to dropping that shit because they knew exactly how to censor that word in a way that it showed up in chat.
Not once, but twice.
Because usually it would be censored in asterisks.
But this guy knew exactly how to type it so that it would show up and we could see exactly what that word was.
And all of us were just like, whoa!
It was fucking crazy.
Uh, bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Doki Doki Doki Doki Doki.
That's me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Most tamed Overwatch conversation.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I need to thank you for the super chat.
Yeah.
So Overwatch is like...
It's a very...
It's a very interesting game.
But yeah, I'm...
I hope I get into...
Red, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope I get into the alpha test because I would love to try it out.
Um...
It'll be very exciting.
But yeah.
Next week is gonna be...
I know I said next week was supposed to be the rest week.
But next week is gonna be a very interesting week for me.
Yeah.
It's...
It's gonna...
You guys will see in the schedule soon of why.
Why it'll be a very interesting week for me.
But it's...
It's a lot.
It's a lot of stuff.
I still haven't figured out my party animals team as well.
I was supposed to figure it out by today.
But I asked...
I'm gonna give them the...
I'm gonna figure it out tomorrow.
So, we'll see.
It's supposed to be today but then...
Maybe they'll let me wait until tomorrow.
Is that good?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Congrats on master!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Happy at least elimination day, Doki.
What does that mean?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Um...
I'm also like...
Okay, also by the way, should I resize myself smaller for Overwatch streams?
I noticed like, am I too big on the screen guys?
Do you think I should be smaller?
I was worried that I cover up too much of the gameplay.
So if I ever do another Overwatch stream...
ZECO THANK YOU FOR THE 50 GIFTED CHIPS!
THANK YOU, THANK YOU!
I like big, Doki.
No, bigger.
Full body left side.
Guys, you won't be able to see the HP on the left side.
Yeah, that head is huge.
That's where my brain goes.
Yeah, I can make it a little... I'll make it a little bit smaller.
I don't know if I'll ever do an Overwatch stream.
Again, maybe I'll just do like a stream where I just play... just get top 500 and that's it.
I don't have no plans on ending top 500.
Because the reward system...
For Overwatch... for Overwatch is just not...
It's just not like something I care.
The rankings are really fun.
Doki, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, I just play to have fun.
I don't really care about rank anymore.
I just think like... I just think like the reward...
If the rewards were worth it, I'd definitely play more.
But the rewards was 100% not worth it at all.
Haha!
It's just... it just... it just was like... it's not... it's like... it's like some fucking...
What was it?
It was... it's like the tagline that lasts for one season.
Like I don't care.
I don't care about that.
I don't care about... if it was forever like the icon is raised, then I care a little bit more.
But the fact that it's just like a tagline that only lasts for one season is just not worth it.
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I want Doki so big we can see the tomato inside.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you... thank you!
songs Let's see.
It's only the tagline.
So when you get top 500 in Overwatch 2...
You get like this tagline that just says top 500 Challenger something that like shows people that you ended in top 500.
But if you lose it after one season, so they go away and that's it.
That's it!
That's it.
I was like, I don't care.
I don't care.
If it goes away, like, what's the- what the fuck's the point, you know?
So like I don't mind just touching top 500 on stream because usually in the past I never stream my rank sessions because when I get like super serious or like barely, when I get super serious in rank I don't stream my rank sessions because I cannot fo- like,
you know, I talk to you guys and play at the same time So, you know damn well I am not focused at all When am I playing on stream?
But when I play off stream, I play off stream, of course I'm like super focused and I actually like pay attention to my surroundings and everything.
Any plans on more Apex?
ALGS got me high.
I haven't watched ALGS this season.
Honestly, I think if I asked for like drops on my Twitch account, they would give it to me but like I I honestly like I usually watch during I watch for like the finals like the finals finalists.
This is like what is it?
What is it called?
It's uh split one, so I'm not like as like Also, I haven't done a watch-along of it so And like I'm honestly like I'm just waiting for I'm just waiting for like the new update because for the new legend and everything um Only thing is Yeah,
no thought head empty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So if you're a tomato and thief, doesn't that make you a kleptomato?
Grats on masters.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Uh, Splatoon 3.
No.
Splatoon has made me the most toxic person ever.
Because in Splatoon, you can't talk to anybody.
So you can't verbalize your hatred for your teammates.
Uh...
So, Splatoon has been the game that made me the most toxic I can ever be in rank.
And it's also really tilting because it's on Nintendo...
It's on Nintendo servers.
And Nintendo is not great with latency and stuff.
And because of that...
Like, um...
Connections are fucking terrible as well.
And like, so when somebody DCs, it's just losable.
And you don't even get like rank protection or anything.
And I just fucking hate Nintendo servers.
Like, I just don't understand why the latency can be so bad.
I don't understand.
Like, you have so much money.
What do you do with your money?
Like...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was watching your Overwatch stream from my TV at work today.
So then I got stuck doing it.
I was doing paperwork so you can cover as much of the hunt as you want.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
I was very toxic.
I would actually like slam things if I lose.
And like, I would...
Oh my god.
I was...
It was so bad.
It was so bad for Splatoon.
And the player base for like Splatoon is also like not that high.
Like you would think Overwatch player base is pretty bad.
But Splatoon player base is absolutely terrible.
Because majority of the players are in Japan.
And like the NA players are like...
Yeah.
Never.
It's all in Asia.
So like the connection is like even more terrible.
But like they'll never...
Nintendo is just too big to fail.
I don't know why we always go back to Nintendo.
But...
It doesn't matter what they do.
The moment they release something remotely nostalgia bait.
People just forget everything.
They...
If Nintendo one day does something so terrible that like...
People actually start boycotting.
All they have to do is just release the new Smash Bros or a new Zelda game.
That's...
That's really it.
Like they don't have to do anything.
They don't need to do anything.
Everything is forgive...
I...
Okay someone says everything is forgiven by the next direct.
I'm so sad.
I miss E3.
I miss...
E3 was so fucking hyped.
I love all the...
I love...
I wish we could just... I wish E3 was still going on so we can do like watch-alongs of E3.
I miss... like those were so fucking hype.
And even if like some... like some of you were like, yeah, but the recent shows were so cringe.
That's the best part!
When it's cringe and you can make fun of it.
Like Summer Game Fest, it's not the same.
It's not the same.
Even the booths were so good too.
The booths on E3 presentations were so good as well.
It's just not the same.
E3 cringe was amazing!
Exactly!
Even with the... but then you were like, what about the Gamer Awards?
The Gamer Awards... oh my god, bro.
The Gamer Awards is not... it's just... it's just not... it's just trailers.
It's just game trailers.
There's no like performances or anything.
Other than the music performances and stuff.
Not every game company is doing their own fucking direct.
Because Nintendo did it first and then everybody else copied it.
But it's so... I'm gonna say it.
The Nintendo Direct is so boring!
It's not... it's not hype anymore.
It's so boring!
Remember when like... wait, it was the robot chicken?
Oh my god!
Remember when like...
wait, it was the robot chicken?
Remember when like... wait, it was the robot chicken?
Oh my god!
Remember when like...
wait, it was the robot chicken?
Remember when like Nintendo did the robot chicken thing?
Was that E3?
Or was that like...
A different one.
That shit was so funny!
It was so good, too!
And now, Direct's just so...
Yeah!
E3 inspectors 2013!
Bro, for those who didn't realize...
E3 did like...
Back when Nintendo still participated in E3, they did a robot chicken parody.
I felt like, honestly, not gonna lie, I feel like Nintendo was much more chill back then compared to now.
I think compared to now, they're definitely more harsh and strict with things.
Oh yeah, the Muppets too!
The Muppets won!
They were so good at publicity back then.
I don't know what happened.
I feel like now they're much more strict.
Red, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Not just Reggie, but other stuff too.
I mean, it makes sense because the guy is run by...
Nintendo America is run by the guy named Bowser.
Right?
Yeah, Iwata-san too.
I feel like they were much more...
chill back then compared to now.
Ummm...
I'm trying to remember, like.
Yeah, I don't, I'm not a huge fan of...
I'm not a huge fan of game companies.
Doing... GAME COMPANIES doing like...
Like, their own presentations, because it feels less hype.
I'm not hype about game releases these days.
Especially when everybody just leaks what they're saying.
And usually like, you don't...
Because everything gets leaked now that you don't get hyped over a game release when it just shows up out of nowhere.
You know?
Like world premieres and stuff like when nothing was ever said about the certain game and then suddenly you find out on E3 alone.
And everyone was like, Wow!
Wow!
Now you know everything that's gonna come out.
Times were simpler.
Yeah.
Everything was so much more simpler back then.
Now I feel like... now games are... game releases are not as hyped anymore.
I don't know.
I mean we do have like a lot of indie games and stuff.
Indie games are now... now like more popular than like AAA games and everything.
Because like they get to make whatever they want to make.
And they're not governed by the corporate executive board that was like, no you should change that and this.
So a lot of indie game devs are just doing whatever the fuck they want.
And not having...
not having to worry about trying to fit into whatever the exec wants.
But indie games don't really make a lot of...
Indie games don't really make multiplayer FPS games.
Where are the developers making games for me?
For me!
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna play single player games.
I wanna play multiplayer FPS games.
That I can solo queue.
So I don't have to look for play collab partners.
Haha.
Red thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's just...
All we have is just Apex and Overwatch.
Hahaha.
Um...
I was gonna say...
Oh yeah!
You guys hear about Helldivers 2?
Haha.
Fucking rest in peace that game died.
Hahaha.
It's too late.
They can't do anything to save...
They can't...
They can't do anything to...
To...
To save the game now.
Lucky for them.
EDF is coming out too.
So...
Yeah.
It's already over.
The moment...
Oh what happened?
Um...
Basically...
They made you...
Required to have a...
PlayStation account.
To link your PlayStation account...
To Helldivers 2.
Even though it's on Steam.
People didn't like that cause there's extra steps.
Hahaha.
Wait Steam is actually giving refunds to people?
Oh thank god Valve.
Thank god Gabe.
Gabe always knows what's...
Gabe has to have like...
The fucking best...
Like publicity...
PR team...
In the fucking world.
Cause he's a true gamer.
Gabe is a real fucking gamer.
And I'll be so sad...
If Valve ever goes...
Gets on the stock market.
And gets an executive board.
Because...
That's when everything will go downhill.
Uh...
Hahaha.
Deadpool thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gente...
Don't shoot my baby like this...
You can still walk it back.
Oh...
Somebody's coping.
Looky that...
For...
Poor Fuu...
Fu...
Coping that they can return from this.
You know...
Okay gamers do forget.
But like...
The thing about gamers...
Is that you have to have a big enough...
Reputation...
You have to have something...
That will make gamers wanna come back to you.
But like...
I'm gonna say Helldivers 2...
I don't...
Like...
You gotta be like big enough...
Like Nintendo...
To be able to recover from this.
Like...
Hahaha
And Heldivish2 does not have that reputation, unfortunately.
I don't think Heldivish2 is...
The thing is, the thing is, the only way...
The only way I see Heldivish2 coming back from this is if Sony makes an apology.
And I don't think Sony is going to make an apology.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Truly the best PR strategy.
Do nothing and watch other companies make mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think they're going to apologize.
Let's see.
Razzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They hung us away a lot because they actually have redeeming features.
Someone didn't look at the news recently.
I still love Nintendo though.
I guess it's because I still I'm just a consumer.
I'm just a consumer that's stuck in...
That's stuck because the properties they own are just too good to leave.
I do miss E3.
I think it's just like... I think like watching... doing watch-alongs of like...
like you know... like game announcements and game news just isn't the same.
Just isn't the same.
The memes are not as good too.
I think it's the memes.
The memes that come out of game announcements are just not good.
They're just so boring that people can't make memes out of it.
The only memes we got out of like game announcements were...
were the fucking... what was it?
The one with the kid fucking...
What's the word?
The kid just showed... a random kid just showed out of nowhere.
Just crashes the E3 and I see crashes the game awards.
That was like the only meme that came out of the game awards.
The game awards.
Corinne, thank you for the five.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
Swibbly, Sony apology.
We're sorry you felt this way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nedverse, I don't even want to think about what happened.
The game goes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Oh yeah.
I'm trying to like...
I don't... what are some good games coming out too?
By the way guys.
Guys, you guys know what...
What are some of the...
What some of some good games are coming out soon?
I can't even...
I don't even...
I can't even like think of any good games coming out recently.
EDF?
Other than EDF.
EDF...
Uh...
Stock...
Oh, Silksong.
Sycopium.
I mean like the next couple of months guys.
The next couple of what months?
I guess someone was like...
Silksong.
Copium.
It's not...
Cope!
Oh, Hades 2!
I'm so sad I didn't get into the beta test.
I wanted to get into the beta test for Hades 2.
And do like a sneak peak stream.
But like I couldn't...
I couldn't get into...
I couldn't get into the beta test.
But I wanted to try it out on stream.
Stellar Blade.
Yeah, but that's already out.
Dad, I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
System Shock 2.
Enhance the distance forever on the radar.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Overwatch 3.
Yeah, I know Wukong is coming out.
But that's like...
Like quarter four.
What was it?
It's at the end of the...
The end of the quarter or something.
So it's gonna be a while before...
It's gonna be a while before...
Before it comes out.
So...
I don't know.
Titanfall 3.
I'm coping.
I don't know.
I can't think of like any...
Any good games that are gonna be coming out soon.
Chat.
Like how people were like...
Elden Ring.
Elden Ring DLC.
Guys, I haven't played Elden Ring.
Dragon Ball Z Sparkling Zero.
Is that a...
Okay.
Dragon Ball Z Sparkling Zero.
Is that a fighting game?
Or an adventure game?
For Dragon Ball Z?
Because that's basically a majority of Dragon Ball Z games.
Oh, it is.
Okay.
I...
Almost shit.
I wish...
I said it before in the Sandland playthrough.
But I wish...
I really do wish they make other types of adaptations.
Of anime games.
That's not just fighting games.
There's so much lore to it.
You know why?
It's because they need to get this shit out fast.
Before like anime...
The anime series dies.
Like that's the thing.
They're so scared.
It's the easiest.
Yeah, it's one of the easiest.
They're so scared that the hype is gonna die out.
Um...
That hype is gonna die out.
That they always make like fucking fighting games.
I'm not talking about Dragon Ball Z.
Because it makes sense.
Dragon Ball Z.
Uh...
Fighting games makes sense.
But there's like games that just doesn't fucking make sense.
It just...
It just doesn't make sense.
And it's...
Then they're like...
Sometimes they're fucking terrible too.
I don't...
I don't get it.
Um...
And it's like...
Because it's easy to make.
It's cheaper.
And it's also like...
You want to get in.
You want to get in on the hype before it's over.
And uh...
And like there's so many...
It's crazy.
I...
The thing I hate about like how anime series...
Anime series goes...
Is that...
People...
They're so scared about losing hype.
That like some of the anime shows don't even have time to like sink in for people.
That by the next season...
Like the next like...
It was like...
Oh winter, spring, fall, summer rolls out.
Like it's forget it.
Like people forget about it.
There's so many animes that are releasing almost every season.
That like it's so hard for any show to even like build an audience.
And I hate it.
Like every season like 40 plus animes get released.
It's so competitive.
It's all hype based.
Yeah.
And then the moment...
The moment the season of it ends.
People forget about it.
It's over.
Hahaha.
Like...
Like I hate it.
Because it doesn't even build up the fan base of like...
It doesn't build up the fan base of people.
Yeah the market saturations and stuff like that.
There's so many types of animes like that.
Unless you're probably like the big fucking four or something.
Influx thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
Don't know about the other dragoons but my biggest recent game is like a dragon.
Besides fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't...
I've never played any of the Yakuza games.
But they're so so long.
I know because like my dad played the Yakuza games.
And um...
And like it took him fucking...
I don't even know if he beat it.
It took him fucking forever.
He doesn't play it anymore.
So I assume he beat it.
But it's a very very long game.
Um...
Envy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dragonball Cacker is an adventure game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
16 bit frost.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki I need another $30 for frostbunk.
And possibly Dragonball Z.
And stock too.
And uh more to come.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh cucumber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
New lunch.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Ah thank you.
Thank you.
I can't wait for the visual novel crossover.
Anime fighter featuring school days.
Clannad and Doki Doki literature club.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um I just think like uh I just feel like...
I feel like...
People really should...
Slow down with the anime releases.
Like just space them out more.
Because there's apparently I like I don't watch a lot of anime.
Um because I don't have time to read subtitles.
Well uh I don't have time to read subtitles while playing.
Um while doing work or playing something.
So I don't watch a lot of anime.
But I've always heard how how like people would be like.
Oh man this this anime show was so underrated.
And people already forgot about it.
And if someone was like bro when that was this anime.
When X insert X anime got released.
Um it was like that one the most hype anime is out there.
But people already forgot about it.
Because there's so many animes that's being released almost every season.
That like um even really good ones get like like forgotten and stuff.
Like I feel like a lot of people already forgot about.
What was it the the one with all the animals as like students students or something.
God what's that anime called?
I already forgot.
Remember when like um I got reincarnated as a slime.
That shit was like one of the biggest show anime.
Yeah Beastars.
I feel like Beastars is already people already forgot about Beastars.
But when that anime came out.
So many people were like so hyped about it.
And like like talked about it all everywhere.
And then like it died out.
And then there was what was it?
And then there was that fucking other anime.
With reincarnated as a slime.
No one really talks about that anymore.
Slime is literally airing right now.
Yeah but no one talks about it like the time when it first came out.
And there was that other one with the spider.
Remember that fucking anime reincarnated as a spider?
That one.
No one talks about it anymore.
Because after the first season.
Unless you're like big big.
So it's like I did not even know there was a new season.
And then but we don't talk about one punch man.
One punch man like fucking like shot itself in the foot.
Like that's on them.
And then did you guys know?
I don't even know if it came up.
Blue exorcist.
Oh my god.
All I'm saying.
That when blue exorcist first came out.
That was not gonna lie.
I feel like blue exorcist was like one of the fujo bait anime's out there.
Bro everybody loved that shit.
Like.
And that was the show.
And then when it ended.
Nobody cared.
And now nobody cared after it ended and stuff.
And then apparently.
Apparently it's getting a new season.
It's getting.
Isn't it?
It's getting a new season right?
Or did it air?
Did it already aired?
Like.
Yeah.
They made.
Stop making up for it.
Fake shows.
Yeah.
No.
It is airing.
Nobody cares now.
No one talks about blue exorcist.
Even though like it was one of the fucking shows of.
Of like.
Um.
The show of the season.
And now it has a new season.
It got a revival.
And people were like.
Are like.
Oh my god.
Nobody cares.
Oh yeah.
And then there's free.
Holy fuck.
No.
If I say blue exorcist was fujo bait.
Fucking free was fujo bait as hell.
Because like.
At least Yuri on ice.
Like it's implied that they got together.
Free they're just all really really good friends.
Like.
Yuri on ice at least it's implied.
But free it was just.
They're just homies.
But like.
People can dream.
Yeah.
Friends.
They were dating in my heart.
They're just best buds.
Free is and they were roommates.
The anime.
They're just really really good friends and roommates.
I don't know what you're implying.
I'm getting married in Yuri on ice.
Yeah.
And apparently they.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if you guys heard about the controversy of.
Uh.
Yuri on ice.
But like.
They recently cancelled the movie.
Like officially cancelled the movie.
And like.
Some fucking.
I saw like people were like.
You know.
Reacting very negatively about it.
Because like.
Yuri on ice is like.
Um.
Is like.
Was.
Has a very like deep underground fandom.
Now it's like has a cult following at that point.
Because it's been like forever since they made new content for it.
And like apparently like remember I was reading on Twitter.
Because it was trending on Twitter.
And people were saying like.
People were like.
Oh.
Um.
There's some behind the scenes shenanigans.
As to why Yuri on ice was cancelled.
And I was like.
What the fuck is going on?
People were like.
The director of some behind the scenes shenanigans.
As to why we never got Yuri on ice the movie.
The conspiracies.
Yeah.
Um.
Never black butter aired too.
Oh yeah!
They fucking remade Black Butler!
Or the new season.
I don't know.
Can you think of the super chat thing?
And they didn't care.
No one cares!
It's actually crazy.
That no one really like talked about the Black Butler shit.
Two.
There's just so many things that like.
Like there's so many animates and stuff that comes out.
Wait Beastars was the anime?
I thought it was an anime.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, they did.
They aired a new anime for Black Butler.
But people just glossed over it.
It's just... every season, only one or two animes are like the biggest things ever.
And if you're not... and they fit the two anime, like the biggest...
Like for like... oh, like summer anime.
The summer anime is... insert anime here.
And there can only be two.
I feel like.
I feel like there can only be two.
And then even though there's like other animes that might be really, really fucking good.
If they meet the quota of two, then it's over.
People don't care.
It's just... it's just forgotten.
It could be like really, really fucking good too.
But it doesn't matter.
They already met their quota of two good animes.
There's only a... yeah, there's only a limited amount of attention that goes around.
And oh my gosh.
I tried... I tried to watch Oshinoko.
I couldn't.
I watched like two episodes.
And I got depressed.
Because I was like, this is too fucking real.
I couldn't keep watching.
I got so sad.
This is too real.
Oh yeah, they did a reboot of Shaman King 2.
They did a reboot of Shaman...
There's so many fucking reboots.
Oh my gosh.
I hated anime's name.
Nostalgia baiting now.
It's nostalgia baiting.
Noooo.
I thought we could get away with nostalgia baiting.
Express.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy May the 4th, emergevenge of the 5th from Australia.
Doki.
Is there any...
Clone Troop...
Trooper character, squad, legion, color, patterns that you like is your favorite?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know about Clone Troopers.
But I want to be a Sith Lord.
Because at least Sith Lords...
I remember you guys told me when we were playing that Star Wars game, you guys were like, uh, uh, if you are a Jedi, you have to be pure.
And then when you guys told me like pure, I didn't, I was like, oh, okay, that makes sense.
Cause you gotta be like, you know, a good person.
And you guys were like, no, you can't even have a family.
And I was like, oh my God.
And it like registered like all Jedis are technically virgins.
I was like...
Yeah, they can't not even like a little...
They can't even feel love.
It's crazy.
They're actual wizards.
They can't even feel love.
I was like, holy shit, bro.
It literally like, not my Christian friendly channel.
Except for that one guy.
Who's like, oh, I'm a Christian.
Who's like, who's race that needed to be repopulated.
So they gave him the one exception.
And even then he has to like not love his family, which is so fucked up to think about.
Like, voluntarily celibate.
Yeah, you can't have any attachment.
Why the fuck would you be a Jedi?
Civilians are cooler.
Civilians sound so much cooler because of that.
Uh, Faye, thank you for the Akka soup.
Bah, thank you.
I mean, they can continue the bloodline.
Jedis can't.
I hope Spice and Wolf does the opposite since no one cared when it originally aired.
And then people love this.
So maybe the remake people will care from the start.
Maybe I'm just going to sit and cope now.
Thank you for the Akka soup.
Thank you.
But they're evil, Doki.
So?
But they're rich though.
And they can bang.
I'm not going to lie.
How can they continue the bloodline?
How can they get the ladies?
They get the ladies.
Um...
Yeah.
If evil, why hot?
Exactly.
I just think...
But yeah, that's my rant about anime.
Even though I don't watch a lot of anime in general.
I just think it's dumb that...
A lot of really, really well animated anime shows are forgotten.
Because there's always...
There's just too many being released.
And there's always a quota.
It's like...
If there's more than two good anime being released.
The third plus...
Third, fourth, fifth, sixth good anime will not be noticed.
Because people don't care enough.
Uh...
KJ, thank you.
Welcome back to the tomato farm.
Welcome back.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Star Wars romance fanfics aren't counted because cooties counter the...
The cool orients.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
What other things do I want to talk about?
I also don't like how...
I hate...
Okay.
I hate binging...
I hate shows that are supposed to be bingeable.
Um...
I think like...
Series that you can binge in one sitting...
Has killed our love for like shows.
Because our...
Because like...
We forget about them after it's over.
Like...
I think like binging shows is such a bad concept.
Because...
Uh...
Because like...
You know...
You consume everything in one go.
That there's no hype going...
Yeah.
It kills the hype.
I honestly think it kills...
Um...
It kills the hype instantly.
For like shows.
And I really hate that culture in general now.
Because like...
So...
Some really really good shows get forgotten so easily.
That it's so hard to build any fan base in general.
Um...
If it's like really good.
And I think that's like one of the worst things right now with the binging con...
Culture.
Uh...
By size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're using your top 500 to count today.
Remind me a question I want to ask.
What do you consider your greatest achievement in video games is?
Getting sponsored by my favorite games is like when...
I'm not sure.
I think my greatest achievement in video games...
Because I spent so much money and time playing this game.
And then when I get sponsored by them.
They're paying me.
So in the end.
Like I made back the money I spent on that game.
And so I...
I think that's like my...
I think that's like my greatest achievement.
Because it's like...
It's like I get paid back.
You know?
Like the money just comes back and more.
Uh...
Let me thank you for the 10 gift of chips.
Thank you.
Uh...
Yeah.
The cash back strats.
Exactly.
Speaking of cash back strats.
Have you guys heard about my Fortnite code?
Uh...
You can use my Fortnite creator code at DokiBird.
Whenever you purchase anything on Fortnite.
So...
So like you know.
You're already gonna purchase something anyway.
You know?
You're already gonna purchase something.
So you might as well like...
You know?
Use the creator code.
The infinite money glitch.
Oh my god.
Okay.
So...
I don't remember who I was having this conversation with.
I think I was like talking to somebody who knows like a Fortnite creator.
And like they can literally...
When Fortnite was like...
When they were like at the peak of Fortnite content creation.
Like as a Fortnite streamer.
They literally made like...
I think like...
Five hundred thousand dollars per month.
Of the Fortnite creator code at its peak.
I was like...
Half a million dollars via Fortnite creator code.
Back when Fortnite was at its fucking peak.
I don't remember who the streamer was.
It was not Ninja.
Just so you guys know.
It was not Ninjas.
I'm pretty sure if it was Ninja, it would be a million dollars.
A million.
A million per month if it was Ninja.
But like...
It was some fucking Fortnite creator.
Like a Fortnite streamer years ago.
Years ago.
They could like passively make 500 G's per month.
And I was like...
That is fucking insane.
Insane.
Like, oh my god.
No wonder they stream at Fortnite every day.
Bro, that shit...
That shit makes...
Bank!
Holy shit!
Yeah, passive income.
Because there's a lot of little kids...
using their mama and papa's credit cards to buy Fortnite skins.
And...
That shit says...
That shit like makes so much money.
Guys, I'm gonna...
Well, the Fortnite hype is over.
So...
I'm sorry to say...
But like...
It's too late now.
It's too late to start now, guys.
It is!
It's actually crazy!
To be able to make that much...
off of like one fucking month?
Oh my god!
The Fortnite hype is over.
That's why, guys.
That's why...
I need them to quickly come out with a new...
massive multiplayer game.
So I can get good...
So I can get really, really good at it.
And then become the next ninja...
of that game.
And then pray to god they have a creator code.
So I can make...
500,000!
Guys...
That's why I'm always begging for another...
Another ma...
Like, multiplayer FPS game.
Or TPS.
I'll even take TPS, guys.
I'll even take TPS.
I'm willing to settle.
So I can be the next...
ninja.
Or tens.
Or shroud.
And then make so much fucking content...
of that one game.
And I'll be THE VTuber that plays...
that's really good at this one game.
I'll be...
I'll even communicate!
I'll even do callouts in Marvel!
I swear.
If Marvel Rivals becomes the next...
I...
I ple...
Okay.
Honestly...
I don't...
Not gonna lie, though...
I don't think Marvel Rivals...
will...
Um...
Honestly...
I don't know.
I mean, it has potential.
But like...
I've stopped...
like, hoping...
I've...
Guys...
I'm sorry...
But I've stopped...
believing.
But...
It's...
It seems like a...
quick...
cash crab.
I...
Our only hope...
is if, like...
what's the company...
What's the game...
game company that makes...
Valorant and...
League again.
What are they called again?
Riot.
My only hope...
is if Riot makes a Battle Royale...
or a Team-Based Shooter.
That's my only hope.
Because they'll do...
everything they can...
to pump millions of dollars...
into the game...
to make it work.
We all thought CSGO 2 would save us, but CSGO 2 practically killed CSGO.
We all thought the finalist would be the next hype, but then it died so fast.
Please, Riot Games, make a Battle Royale or a multiplayer or a fucking team-based shooter.
Please... Riot is doing major... No!
They're making a fighting game, their next step is a team-based shooter or Battle Royale!
No!
I miss the Battle Royale genre.
I miss it so much.
I remember we used to rule the world.
Now we're just like StarCraft.
Now we're just like...
Now we're just like strategic games.
Fighting games are trending now.
I miss when PUBG was the way it is now.
There's just too many hackers in PUBG.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I guess the finalist met its finale.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's the fighting game era now.
I mean, fighting games were always super popular.
I used to watch... I mean, I watched EVO quite often.
I watched it on and off.
I used to... I haven't actually...
I haven't watched EVO in like three years?
Two years?
In two years because I never had the time.
But before...
Like, you know...
Two to three years.
But then like when I had the time, I would watch EVO.
But usually the finalist.
Because like that was like the most hype.
The EVO finals.
But...
Like fighting games have always been popular.
Because they have such a die-hard fan base.
And like the thing about like fighting games is...
I mean, it's similar with like shooters.
Where like aim can translate to any type of game.
And like usually fighting game...
Fighting game players...
Like esports players...
They can like...
They can transfer their skills to like different types of fighting games.
So because like the combos are usually like...
Not like that...
Not similar in a way.
But you can transfer like how...
Like different types of...
Like you can transfer it easily to different types of fighting games.
And that's why like...
I know like esports pros in fighting game genres would be like specialists.
They won't be like specialists in one game.
They would like...
They would be...
They would like know how to play multiple fighting games.
And also win...
Win competitions and tournaments in different types of games within fighting games.
So they don't have to be like just like...
Oh, they're only specialized in this one game.
They can like literally enter so many different games as a player.
And yeah, the...
It transfers from game to...
It easily transfers from game to games.
Yeah, like Justin.1 and SonicFox.
Yeah, they're...
Yeah, that's what I was like thinking about too.
Hmm.
So I don't see like fighting games as like...
I feel like they've always been popular.
I don't think they're like...
Oh, they're like...
It's a new rise.
It's a new trend now.
I think they've always been pretty popular.
Because of Evo.
SleepyAsh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just...
I just wish...
There was like...
I was...
I wish I can adapt.
My genre is dying.
What do I do?
Adapt or die.
But what if I'm too slow to adapt?
I don't know.
Um...
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
It's been an hour already?
Holy shit.
I can talk for so long.
I really am a yapper.
The learning curve is too steep.
I think it's cause like...
Oh my gosh.
There's so much stuff to do.
There's just so much stuff to do.
It's hard to make time these days.
So...
I need to like do stuff.
So like that's like one of my biggest issues.
It's just hard to make time to learn new video games and stuff.
There's a lot to learn.
Like I had like friends that were like you should learn League.
Bro by the time I get good at League.
League people have been playing League for fucking 10 plus years.
Like that's just impossible.
You should not... I also like I don't like MOBAs.
I really... I really don't like MOBAs.
And there's too many characters in League 2.
And then they'd be like, but like, oh you should learn League, you might like it.
I'm like, bro, by the time I even like figure out how to fucking play League, the game would have moved on.
The game people would be...
Like people who were like at my level when I started would be like 50 times better than me.
Do not learn League, it's not successful.
Thank you for the super chat, Jayah.
Thank you.
Also like, it's such a money pit.
Same with Riot, same with Valorant.
People always complain about skins and like currency prices for like other games like Apex and Overwatch.
But League and Valorant is the biggest money pit ever when it comes to skins.
Because they already set the grounds on like the default of how expensive they are.
That like people don't complain.
Because we're all sheep.
Because we're like, oh that was the default anyway, so it's fine.
Like knife skins being fucking $40.
Like what the fuck is that bullshit?
Like...
I'm just being like...
Oh my god.
But like an Overwatch skin would be like maybe like $5 to $10.
Like a fucking knife in Valorant.
It would be so goddamn expensive.
And people will buy multiple skins of that too.
Like multiple cosmetics from that.
And it's actually... I feel like...
I don't want to say that and then I buy Fortnite skins.
But like...
Fortnite skins are funny.
The thing is I buy Fortnite skins for the crossovers.
But Valorant is like purely like cosmetics.
Like the design from the store itself.
Like I buy Fortnite skins because I want to be fucking Vegeta in Fortnite.
Like I want to be Peter Griffin in Fortnite.
Like it's funny.
It's just funny.
And it's still cheaper than the fucking Valorant knife.
It's still cheaper.
But...
Oh my god.
I just think like...
They're so smart.
Make the default so fucking expensive that the consumers don't care.
It's so smart!
Oh my god!
It really is!
Because people complain about the cost of skins.
For every other game.
Except for Valorant and League.
And then like...
Well the characters are locked as well.
In League, right?
So like there's like locked characters in League.
And then if meta changes you might as well like purchase the characters and stuff.
So...
They're so smart.
It's just business.
They know how to do business.
Yeah.
You need to unlock them.
They just...
They just really know how to do business.
Like this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God knows how much money I'm willing to spend for the...
Exactly!
I'm willing to spend a lot of money for the funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
League players do complain.
It's like the only thing we know how to do.
Yeah, you guys complain.
But you know they're not going to do anything about it.
It's like...
What are you going to do?
Cry at...
They're going to use their $100 bills.
And use it as tissue to cry on it.
It's just like...
They'll be like...
Leave.
Right?
It's just going to be like...
Fine.
Leave.
We can replace you.
Yeah.
The people who complain the loudest are the ones who never...
That is so true.
You will be replaced.
We will do another K-pop collab and we shall replace you.
It's so true!
Like...
People are complaining.
Drop that K-pop collab now.
Conspiracy confirmation.
It works.
It just works.
So true.
It works.
Greg thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Neilowser, Thank you for the super chat thank you thank you.
Leo, Gaming has gone full circle to Barton.
$20 can get you an overwrought skin or full games.
Thank you for the super chat.
Release the KDA sins.
They will be silenced.
If you say the K O O's, I will be silenced.
It just never fails.
It never fucking fails.
They don't even need to do crossovers.
That's how lucrative they are.
They don't need to do crossovers to actually like...
I mean they do like K-pop and stuff, but those aren't like actual crossover crossovers because they're original music.
They're like, they're like original stuff.
But like other games have to do real fucking crossovers to make people play their game.
That's how powerful Riot is.
Riot marketing is so good.
Like Overwatch has to do like collabs with different celebrities and different like anime stuff and like shit.
But like...
But like Riot doesn't have to care.
They just make original content and they don't have to revenue share.
They're like, we don't need a collab with a K-pop.
We're like, we don't need a collab with K-pop people.
We won't make our own K-pop.
And then they...
I remember there was a Sienna with KDA where they replaced...
I think they replaced like one or the...
One of the members, one or two of the members in the KDA squad of the original KDA squad to somebody else because they didn't want to...
I don't know what the controversy was, but they replaced like one or two of the original singers for the original KDA squad because of something.
Like it was a controversy and then no one cared that they got replaced.
It was like...
They're like, whoa, it's not a little different.
It was a huge thing.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't remember why.
I don't remember the controversy.
They just had to be replaced one of the KDA members because of something.
And then because they're like, I don't know what happened, but they replaced one of them.
And then people were like, she sounds a little different.
Oh, well, I still love KDA.
I still love KDA.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Back in my old league days, we used to cry a lot.
They just need to release a new skin for us.
So I'll jump on it.
The cycle continues on to milk us and you shall be milked.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a brutal industry.
Yeah, cheap.
And we shall continue to milk you.
I think I didn't notice that.
Some people didn't notice it.
Yeah.
All right.
Honestly, I don't remember.
This is how good Riot PR is.
I don't remember why.
I don't remember why they replaced her.
It's just it was like something going on and people were like, what the fuck?
But just like anyway, here's some more KDA.
Yes.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How much money do I have to pay for you to do a song as a KDA member?
110,000 Canadian?
One million?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yeah, they're so smart.
Riot marketing is just...
Riot marketing and PR, they're just too good.
You know?
Can't believe they made a game to promote their K-pop.
I heard...
I heard K-pop VTubers are starting to become extremely popular now.
I know I'm not...
I don't really follow K-pop in general.
I used to like K-pop a lot when I was like a really a lot younger.
Like Girls' Generation and Wonder Girls and Rainism.
Ba-ba-meanism.
Like I...
Oh, and Super Junior.
Super Junior was...
For those who don't know who Super Junior was, it was the BTS.
Of the time.
Because I used to go to a school that was like 70% Korean students.
So I knew a lot about...
I knew a lot about like K-pop back then before it was like...
I basically knew K-pop before it got big in like NA.
Because I used to...
I used to go to a school with like 60-70% Korean students.
So...
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
Ba-ba-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da.
Tokyo is a...
K-pop boomer.
Like Super Junior was...
Was like pre-BTS.
She liked it before it was cool.
I'm a veteran.
But now I don't care.
Now I don't know anything about K-pop.
I don't know anything.
Yeah, I have no idea about like what the fuck is hip now.
Because I don't have like my Korean friends to tell me what's hip.
Oh my god.
In four minutes.
Didn't like four minutes to spend and people were so...
Wait, 2...
2NE1.
Is 2NE1 still going?
They had like the most creative name ever.
2NE1?
I love their name.
I love like how they...
It's all the same now.
I think they're Spanish, right?
I really... I used to love the...
I don't know any other songs.
2NE...
Yeah, 2NE1.
And then everyone call it 2NE1.
Yeah!
Oh, they separate now?
They're still popular solos?
But I don't... I don't remember any of the songs they made.
I just remember...
I just love their way...
Yeah, is that how you...
Is it 2NE1?
Yeah.
2NE1.
That's supposed to be like how it's pronounced.
Yeah, that was a K-pop boomer.
I don't follow K-pop anymore though.
But yeah, there's like apparently like...
K-pop VTubers are becoming like super popular.
I was reading about how like...
There's a new VTuber boom in Korea now.
And that's why like a lot of people are doing like VTuber groups based off of K-pop.
Because like...
There is a huge VTuber boom now in Korea.
So that's why like people are starting like K-pop.
Stuff.
Yeah.
Yeah, Plav.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Plav?
Is that how you pronounce it?
It's going like crazy now over there.
So that's why you might be seeing like why a lot of like...
A lot of like people are focusing on K-pop now for VTubers.
Or like a lot of people are doing like K-pop stuff or like focusing on marketing in Korea.
Just because like...
I think like...
Was it Plav or Plav?
I can't...
I've never...
I've only heard like one or two songs because I was curious about it.
Yeah, it's like...
You know how like the VTuber boom in NA because of COVID?
So it's like there's like a...
And like there's a VTuber boom in NA like that was started because like COVID and stuff.
And there was like a VTuber boom in like certain countries and stuff like that because like certain events.
So now the VTuber boom is start...
Is picking up now and starting in Korea at the moment because of...
Because of the VTuber K-pop groups.
And...
Am I pronouncing the name right?
Plav?
Or is it Plav?
I can't believe Doki is going to be a K-pop...
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA And also...
It also helps a lot with the fact that like...
Twitch...
They can't stream on Twitch anymore.
So they have to stream on YouTube.
So like making music is like one of the easiest way.
Uh...
It's PlayV?
Is that right?
PlayV?
PlayV.
Is that how you pronounce it?
So...
Yeah, they're K-pop VTubers now because it's the new thing.
It's...
Well, not new thing but it's the VTuber boom now.
It also like doesn't help that BTS is still in the army.
It's still in the army.
They're still in the army.
So like people are looking at like new...
I guess like new...
Substitutes for it.
And that's why like people have migrated to like VTubers.
Um...
Yeah, cause they're like the BTS VTuber now.
Yeah.
And it's...
Um...
So they're like the VTuber...
I guess you could call them like...
BTS VTubers.
Uh...
BTS is in the army.
Yes that's why they...
They're...
Yes.
Wait... guys, were you under the rock?
They've been in the army for a while now.
That's why...
That's why a lot of K-pop fans have migrated to VTubers.
Because they were trying to find a substitute to BTS.
I was like... they're like... BTS is in the armies?
Were you guys living under a fucking rock?
Yes, that's why.
I think it's like two years.
I'm pretty sure.
I think it's like around two years.
And then they're back.
This has been a minute.
It's like two to three years.
Yeah, two to three years.
So I thought that was like super... super interesting.
But yeah, if you guys don't know...
Twitch like...
I think it was like...
I don't remember the whole thing.
Oh yeah!
I think it was like Korea wanted to...
It was weird.
It's weird.
It's so complicated.
Because like Twitch didn't want to pay the extra fees or something.
So then...
So they're like... now we out.
Because they're like... we're losing money anyway.
So we're out.
To be fair, Twitch is always losing money.
If you guys didn't know, Twitch has not made back their money yet.
They're still in the negatives.
So because like...
Bandwidth and like servers...
Server hosting is like crazy fucking expensive.
And Twitch is already like losing money.
And then...
And then like they...
I think like the ISP wanted to charge more to Twitch.
But then they were like bro, we're already fucking losing money.
Like no.
And then they're like...
And then...
And then I guess like...
I guess like the ISP was like you won't leave.
There's no way.
You need us.
And then Twitch was...
Twitch like was like bet.
And then they left.
And then like...
There was this whole thing.
There was this whole thing where like...
I think like the ISP tried to...
Try to pursue a lawsuit against Twitch.
Yeah, what would you do?
Leave?
And then Twitch was like okay.
And then...
I think like they tried to pursue a lawsuit against Twitch.
But something was like wait, you can't leave.
Here's another...
We're gonna fine you if you leave.
And then Twitch was like...
Bye.
But this part was really little short.
It's getting into this.
But that's it.
So this like it made a lot of...
It really sucked.
Because it meant like a lot of Twitch streamers, even like chatters too, they can't sub to their favorite streamers.
Like a lot of like Korean stream...
Like chatters or like Korean accounts on Twitch, they can't even like sub or do anything...
Now, get it?
I think they can chat, but they can't donate anything, they can't buy anything on Twitch to support their streamers.
So it really sucks for the chatters and also the content creators too.
I know a lot of them moved to Afreeca, is that it?
Afreeca, YouTube, Cake.
I think it's pretty interesting that it basically rejuvenized Afreeca.
Because Afreeca TV, for those who don't know what Afreeca TV is, it's the Korean equivalent to Twitch.
And when Twitch started getting more popular, nobody really used Afreeca anymore.
But because of the Twitch ban, everyone went back to Afreeca.
I remember because Overwatch used to be super popular in Korea.
And a lot of Korean streamers will use Afreeca.
It was completely dead and now it's back now.
Because of Twitch being kicked out of Korea.
So I thought it was really interesting.
It always goes back to Overwatch.
Oh, yeah.
I thought it was really interesting.
The universe is quite an interesting place sometimes.
Anyway guys.
I'm going to call it here.
Because we had a super long Overwatch stream today.
So I'm sorry I couldn't chat longer.
Oh my god, Bite Size!
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Holy shit!
Anyway guys.
I am going to call it here.
Yeah, it's over already.
We talked for like almost an hour and a half, everyone!
So I'm going to rest now.
I always have a great time just chatting with my dragoons.
But I hope we hit 700k soon.
Our first milestone.
Official milestone.
I remember I was like, I hope I get 500k by the end of the year.
I'm going to treat 700k as our first official milestone to hit.
But thank you everybody!
I always have a great time just hanging out and chatting with everyone.
Never think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a nice rest week.
It's not... I'm sorry.
It's not going to be a rest week unfortunately.
There's a lot of things going on behind the scenes.
So it's not going to be a rest week.
But thank you so much for the super chat, Neppers.
Thank you, thank you.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!